unsurprisingly focus on NHS and Strikes
to start to start with the kissed um a
lot of catchy zingers from both sides
without any kind of real progress on
anything fundamental
absolutely Lively pmqs there with with
quite spirited performances for both men
actually on on the state of the NHS and
their respective plans for it all the
respective defense and criticism but
what was really interesting in this pmqs
was right at the top of the hour the
Prime Minister has now answered the
question that he has been avoiding for
weeks about his own personal situation
in terms of Private health care he was
asked repeatedly about it uh by Laura
coonsberg at the BBC on Sunday an
interview he refused to answer the
question he said it wasn't relevant if
he used Private health care when I spoke
to Angela Rayner the deputy labor leader
yesterday and asked her what she thought
she said it's up to him if he does it
but he should come clean uh with the
public and there at pmqs at the top of
the hour perhaps anticipating he was
going to be pressed upon it again by
kierstarmer he gave the answer that
number 10 have been trying to not give
for weeks and weeks and he said I am
registered with an NH
nhsgp I have used independent Healthcare
in the past so that's actually a piece
of news of something the Prime Minister
wanted to avoid answering but just did
at pmqs there in terms of what the
discussion was around the NHS there were
two attack lines really from starma the
first was describing it as the greatest
crisis in the history of NHS taking aim
at the Prime Minister again for not
resolving narcissist's strike saying he
could have done this before Christmas
instead he's chosen to prolong the
misery and then the second sort of line
of questioning from starmer was on
strike laws actually going in there and
actually tackling that head-on and and
using a a catchline I think we will see
a lot where he said when I I Clap the
nurses you are sucking the nurses and
arguing that this will not help resolve
the crisis in the NHS but but equally
Rishi soon out there was was pretty
robust in his rebuttals saying again
that he had to be responsible with the
public finances in terms of of pay
Awards and also criticizing uh some of
the measures that the labor party have
suggested for the NHS uh specifically he
criticized labor for that unfunded as he
put it plans for reform now I asked
Andrew Rayne yesterday if she thought
that the labor party should put
additional money into the NHS the
conservatives put an additional 6.6
billion in funding over the next two
years is it enough many Health Care
Professionals say it's not now laborer
talking about not more money but reform
now he attacked their plans saying that
the plan to buy out GP contracts and he
quoted The Independent Health tank not
field trust would cost a fortune and was
out of date and then the Zinger from uh
soon out there was he said out of date
costing a fortune just like the labor
party but then of course as you said
there were some good lines too from
for not supporting the strike laws
guarantee minimum service levels which
the concept is trying to push through
starmer shot straight back there's not a
minimum level of service any day in the
NHS because they have broken the NHS so
really spirited exchanges from those two
men there and it doesn't feel like in
any way that these Rouse over the NHS
are going to go away particularly when
we have ambulance strikes today there
are more nurses strikes scheduled that
doesn't seem to be resolved and and now
Junior doctors also balloting for
strikes the health secretary couldn't
meet them today but we understand he's
going to try and meet them soon and
storm also in response to uh sunax jab
about the labor party broadly said of
the conservative scratch the surface and
you realize there's nothing there lots
of zingers throughout one of them from
sunak very quickly as I know we're out
of time Beth came after a specific
mention from Stephen Flynn the
Westminster lead of SMP name checking
the Westminster account Sky news's
project and Sam coats in particular and
reference Boris Johnson's million pounds
or so earnings over the last four months
for speeches and sunac had a good a good
repost well yeah that was so so Stephen
Flynn the the New Westminster leader of
the SMP uh praising the Westminster
accounts uh project for shining a light
on where the money goes in Westminster
and using it to attack uh sunak over
Johnson's 1 million of earnings and he
said he did actually kill it they're
quite effectively saying I'm not going
to take a lectures uh from a from a man
who's predecessor Alex salmond uh took
money from Russia Today the the media
organization so it's advising him it's
not worth either of us talking about our
predecessors which was which was a
clever uh reply well worth either way
checking the Westminster accounts
project on Sky News Beth as always
thanks so much